[Applause]
they should be on the wards or in
surgery but they're out here because
they say the pay is too little and the
pressure is too much for us that means
burnout on the level never seen before
for patients most importantly it means
they're not getting the quality of care
they deserve and that we aspire to
deliver so we feel that we've got to
take action we can't be complicit in the
running down of the NHS polling shows
that they do still have the support from
the majority of the public that's what
we found with patients and taxpayers
outside Salford Royal Hospital it's
going to cause a lot of digital option
but at the end of the day the government
sort of talk about that before the bride
to this and they should have sponsor him
and went to something else sooner I
think it will put People's Health at
risk here but it's like acceptable what
do you think is it acceptable
um no I have sympathy for the doctor and
I also have sympathy for the people who
are going to need to use their NHS
because you know concert appointments
you know it's gonna people are gonna
feel even worse
some NHS trusts have canceled half of
their elective surgery this week hitting
cancer Services Orthopedic procedures
and so much more
the unions that represent England's 75
000 Junior doctors say they want a deal
that puts right years of being
undervalued we are ready to have
discussions with them but clearly a
demand for 35 over 20 000 pounds for
some Junior doctors is not fair or
reasonable and that is why we've not
been able to make progress so far that
means summer faces delays for her
gallbladder treatment the pain is
unbearable I broke my ankle before and
I'd rather have that three times again
than have this vein the only way she
felt she could get the surgery she needs
was to take out a loan and go private I
feel really jaded towards the government
who have made us you know maybe put me
in a position where I've got to pay
National Insurance but also pay for
things privately which is you know
essentially what the national insurance
payments are there to do
no Junior doctor wants to run this level
of risk but they say they are so
overstretched and so under appreciated
that there is no other option
four consecutive days of this leaves
acute short-term problems this week but
more long term the government's big
promises to reduce the backlogs
postcovid well they are far more
difficult to achieve
both sides know how much harm this is
doing there will have to be talks it's
just a question of when
Tom partmenter Sky News greater
Manchester